Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten.
Gute Nachrichten, die Pandemie ist jetzt zu Ende. Wie angekündigt.
Ja, Tim und die angekündigten goldenen Zwanziger verzögern sich unwesentlich.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer vierhundertvierundzwanzig vom dritten März zwanzig zweiundzwanzig dritter dritter zweiundzwanzig.
So ein schöner Tag sein können. Ja da sind wir wieder.
Ja. Hallo.
Ja, nach der schönen Sendung mit Thomas äh stoße ich jetzt wieder dazu. Ähm ja, seitdem ist irgendwas passiert.
Ich hätte denn, also wir haben ja an dem einen Abend aufgezeichnet, am nächsten Tag die Sendung veröffentlicht. Da hatte ich ja noch kurze Sorge, ob unser Intro zu den
über Nacht umgeschulten Russland-Expertinnen vielleicht nicht so gut ist,
aber hat sich eigentlich bewahrheitet, ne? Haben alle relativ schnell umgeschult.
Total. Wissen alle richtig Bescheid. Wie wie schon immer. Mhm.
Ich kann ich also wir werden uns zu diesem Gefüge nicht äußern in Ermangelung von Kompetenz die über das hinausgeht was man eben kriegt wenn man die Nachrichten liest.
Was mich an dieser ganzen Lage so ein bisschen nervös macht, ne, das ist eigentlich das Einzige, was mich nervös macht. Ähm.
Ich verstehe nicht genau.
Dieser Putin da will und das macht mich aus zwei Gründen nervös. Entweder.
Trotz ausführlicher Lektüre kann mir jetzt niemand vernünftig erklären.
Erklärt es mir niemand vernünftig, ja, sodass wir hier, was weiß ich, im Dunkeln gelassen werden über die wahre Motivation, ja? Oder.
Das ist nicht logisch nachvollziehbar, was der will und der folgt gar keiner Strategie und ähm das wäre äh also beides wäre irgendwie beunruhigend.
Fürs Erste habe ich mich mit der mit der Hypothese äh angefreundet, dass es dass der dachte,
na ja, also so ein kleiner Einmarsch, da hat die Weltengemeinschaft sich jetzt bisher nie so besonders drüber aufgeregt
dieses Jahr machen wir mal noch ein bisschen Ukraine dazu, ja. Und stimmt ja eigentlich das also nie so viel Gegenwind bekommen hat, wenn er irgendwo ähm einmarschiert ist, sodass ich momentan unter der Arbeitshypothese fahre, dass er sich verschätzt hat.
Aber ähm dass ich hier mit Hypothesen arbeite und nicht genau weiß, was da los ist. Äh irritiert mich dann doch schon.
Also er hat sich unter Garantie verschätzt. Gar keine Frage.
Die Frage ist nur, kratzt sie das jetzt groß und und und trägt das in irgendeiner Form dazu bei äh hier einzulenken und das zeichnet sich meiner Meinung nach derzeit noch nicht ab. Der Schaden,
in Russland davontragen wird, der wird extrem,
groß sein. Also natürlich ist der Schaden für die Ukraine jetzt schon viel viel größer und und und schlimmer und dramatischer und alles. Trotzdem Russland als solches.
Wird.
Na ja, also im Prinzip sonst ins ins Wirtschaftliche äh äh Mittelalter zurückgeholt. Also das davon davon werden die sich,
so schnell nicht erholen.
Und äh nur scheint es halt Putin an dieser Stelle völlig egal zu sein. Und das zeugt schon von so einer gewissen Realitäts- äh ferner äh und so einer Bunker,
Mentalität so, ja, dass er halt ist. Es ist ich sehe schon, wie er da an seinem langen Tisch,
sitzt und und und abzählt, wer jetzt im Raum bleibt, ja? Also das ist.
Dieser lange Tisch zeugt dir davon, dass schon echt viele raus mussten, ne? Also ich meine dieser was ist mit diesem Tisch ey?
Ja, das ist auch irgendwie so ein Eur.
Die hören den doch gar nicht. Wie will der denn da.
Ja aber mal so,
Weißt du, was ich meine? Also es ist das äh scheint schon äh hier eine eine Entfernung der Realität zu sein. Ich nenne die glauben halt einfach ihren ihren eigenen Bullshit mittlerweile. Ne, weil weil sich halt einfach ein Land hat,
herangezogen hat, was was Widerspruch nicht duldet,
Irgendwann steckst du halt in deiner eigenen scheiß Blase festingst. Du kannst ja äh alles rausnehmen und genau das hat er jetzt beschlossen.
Und dann holst du dir erstmal einen langen Tisch.
Ja, ich glaube, der hat das schon vorher, aber ja.
Ich äh wir haben gesagt, wir wollen da äh das wir haben das jetzt als unser Prolog immer gesagt, wenn wir jetzt hier keine äh Militär äh und Diplomatie äh Analyse, weil das einfach nicht unser,
fällt der Expertise ist. Unser Feld der Expertise sind HTTP-Codes.
Und einer ist zum Einsatz gekommen, ja.
Aber da kommen wir gleich zu, die meisten wissen's wahrscheinlich auch schon. Äh gibt es denn ein HTTP Code mit der Nummer? Was ist bei welcher Sendung sind wir jetzt eigentlich, Tim.
Vier 2 vier sind wir, ja, gibt's jetzt gar nicht vorbereitet, aber ähm ja, gibt's, fehlt die Pendency, heißt der ähm.
Okay? Was macht er?
Ähm ja ist auch wieder Web Daff gehört irgendwie alles in diesen Bereich rein.
Ist so ein internes äh Detail wo du so propatis an Dateien hast und ähm wenn diese Propazis irgendwie nicht passen, dann kommt irgendwie so was, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es nicht. Fällt die Mokris, hier ist das ein bisschen mehr.
Uns werden ja immer die HTTP-Katzen empfohlen, aber der HTTP-Hund zu 424 ist auch in Ordnung.
Echte Skips.
Hund empfehlen. Ja, warum nicht? Okay. Ähm.
Übrigens gab's dann doch noch äh ich hatte in einer der letzten Sendungen gesagt, dass äh Web darf eher so ein.
Nicht so ernst zu nehmendes Protokoll ist, stellt sich raus, ja äh Google Drive ne benutzt das und äh,
wo ich noch dachte, habe ich doch gesagt, ist kein ernstzunehmendes Protokoll. Ähm Next Cloud nutzt das auch. Das stimmt äh auch, das hätte ich auch sogar wissen müssen.
Spätestens aus der Inzident Response, wo man dann auf einmal komische äh HTTP Methoden in Lox sieht,
und denkt, was ist das denn? Und dann äh feststellt, ein ganz normales Web DAV. Na ja, okay. Äh also danke für diesen Hinweis, wer DAV ist doch durchaus verbreiteter als man,
meint als jemand, der in einer Welt lebt, wo man tatsächlich mit Dateien arbeitet und auch noch weiß, wo die wo die Pfade sind, dass er in der modernen Arbeitswelt auch schon nicht mehr so.
Also, was ist passiert? Wir kommen zum klaren Thema,
Krieg in der Ukraine oder Angriff auf die Ukraine von Russland und äh konzentrieren uns aber jetzt auf unseren äh unseren Acker.
Nämlich ähm jetzt muss jetzt darf ich bloß keinen schlechten Reim machen, ne.
Keinen rein mit Haka jetzt, sondern Cyber. Wir konzentrieren uns auf den auf den auf unseren Acker, nämlich den des Cyber.
Also äh Phase eins,
Die Invasion auf die Ukraine wurde begleitet von äh einigen ja äh Cyberangriffen. Wir werden wir alle die uns kennen wissen wie sehr ich dieses Wort hasse, äh weil es einfach nur eine,
äh Wortbildungselement mit der Bedeutung, ich habe keine Ahnung, wovon ich rede, ist. Aber ähm,
dieses Wort kriegt man einfach nicht mehr weg. Das ist genauso wie Blockchain.
Das müssen wir jetzt äh müssen wir jetzt noch ein paar Jahre so lange sagen, bis es wirklich allen aus den Ohren blutet.
Also äh übernehme ich diesen Begriff jetzt mal. Äh Angriff auf die Ukraine begleitet von allerlei Cyber. Ähm zum Beispiel ein Viper, der eingesetzt wurde, also etwas, was,
sich verhält wie eine Ransom Weare, aber äh quasi nicht nicht vorsieht, dass die Dateien noch einmal wiederhergestellt werden.
Kann man ähm wenn man so was effizient baut äh sehr viel Schaden mit anrichten.
Vor allem weil man nicht die Dateien löschen muss weil es bei vielen Reis einfach die ersten paar Bites zu überschreiben ne? Schreibst du halt Nullen in den Dateianfang von allen möglichen Dateien. Das heißt du hast sehr viel sehr viel weniger,
Schreibzeit, ne? Also du musst äh ja nicht jetzt irgendwie, was weiß ich, fünfhundert Gig schreiben, sondern eben einfach nur ein paar Bite äh,
äh Kilobyte pro Datei und bist fertig mit einer ähm nur sehr sehr schwer wieder herstellbaren ähm Zerstörung.
Nicht das erste Mal, dass so etwas äh eingesetzt wird wo war ja so bekannt, als dass es eben auch ein russischer ja derartiger Angriff war zur zur Schädigung Schwächung eines anderen Landes.
Warum macht man das im Rahmen einer äh militärischen Aktion primär mit dem Ziel in dem angegriffenen Land schon mal so ein bisschen,
Chaos zu schaffen, ne. Die sind da mit sich selber beschäftigt. Da fallen irgendwelche Dinge aus, da gibt's Probleme, Kommunikation ist gestört ähm,
Das hilft einfach, wenn du beabsichtigst da gerade mal schnell mit ein paar Panzern durchzufahren und dir den Laden äh untern Nagel zu reißen, ne? Wenn wenn die halt neben dir,
noch andere Probleme haben oder kurz vor deinem Angriff.
Denken, dass diese Salberei jetzt ihr größtes Problem wäre und sich damit beschäftigen. Ähm das ist so der Teil, den ich sehe, der im Moment.
Kann sich vielleicht auch ändern, aber bisher habe ich's jetzt nicht anders gesehen. Den, der militärische Zweck von,
Cyberangriffen ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das anders beobachtet hast.
Ja gut, ich meine, wenn man das aus einer militärischen Logik heraus betrachtet, dann hilft natürlich alles, was in irgendeiner Form des Gegners Infrastruktur zersetzt. So und natürlich wissen wir, dass es theoretisch und manchmal auch praktisch möglich ist, von außen,
bestimmte Systeme tatsächlich digital äh außer Gefecht zu setzen. Das mag nicht unbedingt die Regel sein, aber das ist absolut möglich.
Sind einfach online, oft halt einfach direkt am Internet, schlecht geschützt, sind dann irgendwie mit gängigen Hackmethoden,
aufmachbar. Das hängt ja auch immer davon ab, wie wie gut sowas abgesichert ist, wie viel Kompetenz da ist. Und wenn wir jetzt so an Elektrizitätsnetze, äh Wasserwerke,
Heizkraftwerke, äh Kraftwerke generell denken. Natürlich haben die eine bestimmte Elektronik und natürlich,
steuert diese Elektronik-Dinge und wenn's halt jetzt gelingt von außen in irgendeiner Form auf Rechner zu geraten, die äh für den Betrieb dieser Systeme einfach zwingend erforderlich sind.
Die werden dann halt einfach
platt gemacht, gelöscht, rebootet, verändert, Konfiguration angepasst, je nachdem wie man das macht oder auch einfach nur alles verschlüsselt so und dann hier zahlen wir fünf Bitcoin
dann dann kann natürlich schnell hier was kaputt gehen. Wir hatten diesen Fall mit der amerikanischen Pipeline.
Dieser Attacke in in in Texas, was äh für,
wochenlangen äh Ausfall gesorgt hat oder zumindest für einen tagelangen Ausfall mit wochenlangen Problemen und ähm.
Haben keinen Einblick dadrin, wie das da aussieht in den ukrainischen Kraftwerken und sonstigen Infrastrukturen. Ähnliches gilt natürlich auch für Government-Strukturen.
Haben die auch Computernetzwerke, Kommunikationsnetzwerke et cetera und das ist alles äh kann kann alles kriegsentscheidend sein, zumal
Kommunikation zu zerstören schon immer Hauptziel jedes äh,
Angriffskrieges ist. Man will halt erstmal, dass der Gegner nicht mehr in der Lage ist, sich in irgendeiner Form zu koordinieren,
Das äh sieht man dann an Raketenangriffen auf äh Fernsehtürme, äh Internetinfrastruktur, aber eben auch die Angriffe auf Kraftwerke als solche und,
kann digital begleitet werden, aber wie viel Erfolg sie da gehabt haben, entzieht sich unserer Erkenntnis.
Nee, finde ich ehrlich so nicht, dass es jetzt unserer Kenntnis entzieht. Also äh okay, ähm der der wichtige Punkt, um immer mal zusammenzufassen ist,
mit mit deinen mit mit quasi Cyberangriffen auf solche Sachen. Ja, schaffst du eine Störung? Bindest du Kapazitäten, ja? Aber das ist bei weitem nicht so nachhaltig, wie eine Bombe draufwerfen.
Also wenn du möchtest, dass irgendwie ein Kraftwerk nicht mehr funktioniert, dann machst du es halt einfach kaputt. Und äh der Schaden, den du mit einer Bombe oder Rakete anrichten kannst, ist der natürlich sehr viel.
Ähm nachhaltiger, wenn es dir wirklich um die Zerstörung geht. Ja ähm gemessen daran sind jetzt so Cyber-Geschichten, potenziell,
noch nicht so,
nicht so nachhaltig und so ähm dramatisch. Trotzdem haben sie jetzt zum Beispiel äh KAZ gehackt und äh das ist also KA-Sat, ja, Satellitennetzwerk äh über äh Europa.
Über das du unter anderem auch ähm Internet ähm bekommen kannst, ja ähm,
potenziell bis zu 50 Mbit machen an laut Betreiberangab und da sind eben jetzt Teile oder ein vollständiger,
Ausfall, ja? Der sich in Deutschland primär dabei äh darüber äh bemerkbar macht, dass äh bestimmte Windkraftanlagen.
Ähm nicht mehr nach Hause telefonieren können. Die in Deutschland haben wir ja nicht überall Internet und wenn wir dann
gerade Windkraftanlagen darf man ja sowieso nur da bauen, wo weit und breit keine Sau ist, ja und dann muss sie eben sagen, gut, dann kommt da halt so ein Satelliteninternet dran,
äh da gibt's jetzt also das ist zum Beispiel etwas, was wir hier auch merken. Das ist jetzt also diese Windkraftanlagen,
nicht nach Hause telefonieren können, ja? Nur also der das Ziel hier ist,
Störung, ja Sabotage, Kurzfrist, also verhältnismäßig, kurzfristige Störungen, wenn man sich überlegt, was man mit einer Bombe anrichten kann. Dafür allerdings auch potenziell kostengünstig.
Und schafft dem Gegner halt noch mehr Probleme, als man mit der Invasion in der Lage ist ähm zu leisten,
Was hat Russland zur gleichen Zeit gemacht? Bei vielen Webseiten fiel eben auf, dass die,
zumindest wenn man aus Europa Zugriff, ich hatte jetzt keine Möglichkeit oder keine spontane Möglichkeit ein russisches VPN zu nutzen, dass sie mit HTTP418 geantwortet haben. Ja, also entweder haben sie die Seiten komplett runtergenommen,
oder so eine erste Ebene Geoblocking gemacht um äh um sich selbst ähnlichen Ärger vom Hals zu halten.
Jetzt gibt es natürlich bei diesem ja kriegerischen oder militärischen Aktionen immer die Atributionsproblematik, ja du also.
Vielleicht kommen Sie irgendwann mal Jahre später und sagen, diese eine Aktion, die hier stattgefunden hat, das war aber genau dieser FSB-Truppe, die,
da wohnt und die haben an dem Tag noch ein Salami-Brötchen gegessen bevor sie Enter gedruckt haben oder so ja das ist dann teilweise kommt das ja äh äh wird das in in einem hohen Detail grad dann.
Viele Monate oder Jahre später äh von den USA bekanntgegeben, ohne dass die Beweiskette veröffentlicht,
aber so grundsätzlich, wenn dir da jetzt irgendetwas passiert, weißt du nicht, ob da jetzt ein Kriminelle gerade versuchen, dich anzugreifen oder tatsächlich eine eine militärische Gruppierung oder sonstiges.
Ähm.
Eine Sache, die ich äh in in der Regel schon eigentlich Voraussetzung habe, aber die hier an dieser Stelle vielleicht nochmal erklärt werden muss.
Wenn du militärisch agierst, wenn du jetzt sagen wir mal, du bist eine eine Cyber-Armee, ja ähm die.
Die das erklärte Einsatzziel hat, wenn wir uns in einer kriegerischen Auseinandersetzung befinden,
möchten wir die Infrastruktur unserer Gegner stören, ja? Beispielsweise bis jetzt ein russischer, halber Soldat.
Und du weißt, eines Tages,
möchte ich in der Ukraine ähm öffentliche Infrastruktur stören oder bestimmte Unternehmen schädigen oder sonstiges.
Besteht dein Tag nicht da drin, dass du äh zu Hause sitzt und Bücher über äh Angriffe liest, sondern dass du die ganze Zeit versuchst Systeme zu infiltrieren.
Dich da irgendwo drin einzunisten, etwas über die zu lernen, damit du dann, wenn dir der Befehl gegeben wird, so, jetzt darfst du kaputt machen,
quasi deine Spionage und Infiltration umwandelst äh und nutzt und sagst, jetzt ähm steigen wir um auf Sabotage. Das heißt, wenn hier irgendwie,
auf ein paar Minuten genau ein Satellitennetzwerk zu Schaden kommt.
Dann ist das nicht passiert, weil gestern Nachmittag einer angefangen hat,
sondern dann ist das passiert, weil die da seit Wochen, Monaten oder vielleicht sogar schon Jahren drin hängen,
in diesem Fall gesagt haben, alles klar, Befehl, äh wir sollen hier äh die Sachen kaputt hinterlassen. Dass in einer vor vielen Sendung schon mal gesagt, es ist nicht so, dass da einer morgens reinkommt und sagt, ha,
Die sind da schon längst drin.
Digitale Schläfer sind das.
Also so blöd das jetzt klingt als Pazifist und äh äh White Headhacker mit ethischen Prinzipien. Ich würde es als als Armee ja nicht anders machen,
Natürlich ist dein Geheimdienst dafür da, die ganze Zeit Leute zu infiltrieren. Übrigens auch Zufriedenszeiten, natürlich,
Natürlich ist der dafür da, ist deine deine Armee dafür da, eine ähm.
Na ja, dafür zu sorgen, dass sie Schäden anrichten kann und zwar die, die du befiehlst. Und in diesem gesamten Bereich Cyber ist das eben notwendig, das vorzubereiten und da an äh ähm.
Am Ball zu bleiben, ja? Das heißt, sie machen den ganzen Tag nix anderes als Systeme infiltrieren,
versuchen dabei nicht entdeckt zu werden, versuchen etwas über die Systeme zu lernen und dann im Fall der Fälle, wenn der wenn sie es dann eben machen sollen, dort äh Zerstörung anzurichten.
Gut, aber ob du jetzt ne irgendwie ein da ist, da muss man ja einmal sagen, da gibt's ja da gibt's ja dieses äh Donald Trump Zitat, ne?
So das weißt du halt nicht, ne? Ja und und die Internet-Nobody Nose Dog und es wird dir sehr schwer fallen herauszufinden, ob jetzt die äh die rote Armee
bei dir Domain Admin rechte hat oder äh was weiß ich fluppke, ja? Das ist ähm,
halt äh die die Witze die Gleichen. Ähm.
Also du hast die Atributtionsproblematik. So, jetzt gibt's in Russland noch eine spezielle Sondersituation, die ich ja auch durchaus öfter schon gewürdigt habe.
Und das ist die ähm deren sagen wir mal ähm außergewöhnliche äh Cyberpolitik,
die ungefähr so lautet äh liebe Hacker in Russland. Schaut mal hier, Internet, super. Toll, was wir da alles hacken kann.
Von mir aus äh macht da mit eurer was ihr wollt ähm.
Haltet euch aber bitte äh auf fremden Boden. Ihr wisst auch, dass wir euch nicht ausliefern oder sowas.
Aber wenn ihr hier bei uns im Lande Ärger anrichtet,
dann kriegt der auch Ärger mit uns und unsere Kneste sind einfach gar nicht so komfortabel wie sage ich mal,
genügen nicht dem Lebensstandard von jemandem, der jetzt mal ein Jahr lang,
Rancing Wear Business hatte, ne und ein Unternehmen nach dem anderen um um 100000 und Millionen erpresst. Die fahren ja dann teure Autos schlafen in großen Betten mit weichen Matratzen und so. Das ist dann vorbei.
Entsprechend konzentrieren diese kriminellen Banden sich eben auf den.
Auf das Ausland, machen da Sachen kaputt und auch das ist ja eine, sage ich mal, der äh der russischen.
Zuträgliche Situation, wenn die ähm internationale Wirtschaft immer wieder mit Rancing Wear-Gruppen zu tun hat, die dann irgendwelche Bitcoins dafür kriegen, ne, warum sollte,
Vladimir Putin an diesem Zustand etwas ändern. Großartig. Wir erinnern uns, wie überrascht ich war als ähm.
Ah Mensch welche äh Ehe gegen Emo-TED ging dieser eine, weil dieser eine internationale Schlag möglich und dann gab's aber auch noch eine andere Gruppe.
Ähm fällt mir der Name gerade nicht ein, aber wo im Prinzip die hatten diese Pipeline genutzt und da hatte der,
Biden gesagt, pass auf, wir betrachten das jetzt als militärische Aktivität, auf die wir auch militärisch reagieren, hatte mit irgendwie ein,
Putin und kurz darauf äh waren die erstmal äh von Darnen und hatten hatten sich in eine längere Abwesenheit verabschiedet. Das heißt.
Diese kriminellen Banden wissen schon ungefähr, dass sie sich da in einem Rahmen bewegen,
dass sie in einem Rahmen toleriert werden, der sagen wir im weitesten Sinne von der Regierung gesteckt wird. Ja und ich würde davon ausgehen, dass ähm.
Wie in jedem Land, zwischen der gut organisierten Kriminalität und äh der Regierung und den gut durchsetzten Polizeiapparaten eben dann doch äh sagen wir mal vorsichtige, diplomatische Kanäle gibt.
Bergzeit heißt die Gruppe angeblich.
Okay, da war hätte ich jetzt, ich hätte gut, dass du das hast, weil ich hatte an eine andere gedacht. Gibt's ja auch sehr viele. Sowas passiert jetzt.
Wer weiß auch ob's stimmt.
Ja. Das ist die andere Sache, genau.
Klang vielleicht gut genug so ja a Dachs halt, die nehmen wir.
Es gibt eine äh Gruppe, die äh sehr groß in diesem Geschäft ist. Das ist Conti.
Nichts verwandt und verschwigert mit dem Reifenhersteller.
Ja, aber inzwischen wahrscheinlich wertvoller, ne? Ich weiß nicht, wie weit.
Schon sein. Fünfundsechzigfünfhundert Bitcoins? Ja. Angeblich die holen extrem, glaube ich.
Haben die auf ihr holeln die nee. Meinst du die wohl? Okay krass, ich hätte gedacht die also ich würde erwarten, dass die ähm.
Die müssen rodeln, weil die können sich das besten Fall in Ruhe wechseln und ich glaube, das will jetzt keiner machen.
Das wäre natürlich ärgerlich.
Ähm ich ich äh okay, ich wäre jetzt verwundert, wenn die ähm,
Also ich würde schätzen, dass sie auch signifikante operationale Kosten haben, aber okay, andere Geschichte. So Krieg gegen die Ukraine beginnt und Conti positioniert sich pro Russland.
Pro sorry, das muss man glaube ich auch korrigieren pro Putin. Ja, da beten ja viele Leute auch darum ähm,
das jetzt nicht als eine russische Aktion, sondern als eine Aktion von äh Vladimir Putin. Ähm wahrzunehmen.
Ja am Ende betrifft's alle, ne?
Das ist richtig, aber äh ich die sind sicherlich nicht alle dahinter. Ja, aber okay, also diese diese Aktion konnte positioniert sich ähm.
Putin. Passiert kurze Zeit danach,
liegenden interne ähm Dokumente, weil halt irgendjemand ähm aus dieser Conti-Gruppe halt keinen Bock hatte äh über diese diese Situation.
Und äh hat dann ähm eine ähm.
Also vermutlich ein ukrainisches Mitglied der Bande.
Vermutlich ein ukrainisches Mitglied der Bande und hat irgendwie eine ganze Menge äh äh Kram,
äh daraus getragen und veröffentlicht. Was jetzt mal schauen, potenziell erstens sehr viel Fred Intelligence für diese Gruppe äh über diese Gruppe in die Öffentlichkeit bringt.
Gleichzeitig natürlich auch potenziell deren Operationen stören kann und äh es war auch so ein ja eine faszinierende äh.
Situation ist, ne.
Ja äh ja ist immer zeigt sich natürlich auch die die Verflechtung ne. Also es äh mag solche Gruppen in Russland äh weißrussland, Ukraine äh irgendwo in Osteuropa geben, aber dass das im Internet nicht immer alles so klar durch nationale Grenzen getrennt ist, das wissen wir ja auch.
Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass irgendwo Leute Teil so einer Gruppe äh sind, die vielleicht bisher das gemeinsame Interesse Geldraffen äh hatten,
jetzt nicht mehr ganz so äh auf derselben Linie sind. Das ist natürlich relativ hoch. Das zeigt sich hier.
Okay und aus dem Leak kommt dann eben auch ihre primäre Bitcoin-Adresse und da haben sie zwischen April zwanzig siebzehn in Februar zwanzig zweiundzwanzig diese fünfundsechzigtausend Bitcoin
also irgendwie 2,8 Milliarden äh US-Dollar zum jetzigen Kurs einkassiert. Erstaunlich ähm.
Erstaunlich viel Geld, ja. Äh muss.
Man immer immer dazu sagen muss, die sind nicht realisierbar, ne. Also nicht von heute auf morgen.
Nicht von heute auf morgen realisierbar und sicherlich eben auch zu unterschiedlichen ähm.
Bitcoin-Kursen auf dieses Konto eingegangen. Ja, also die haben jetzt nicht,
die Wirtschaft um 2,8 Milliarden erleichtert, sondern da ist natürlich auch massive Schwankungen drin und ähm ja diesen Haufen zu realisieren wird schwierig und ähm wenn jetzt,
Wenn das jetzt stimmt, dass dieses Wallet vorher nicht bekannt war, dass das dieser Gruppe zugeordnet war.
Dann haben Sie jetzt einen also wenn das noch nicht bekannt war, ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht. Ich wäre davon ausgegangen, dass es bekannt ist, aber offenbar ist es das nicht. Hm,
Dann haben Sie jetzt ein Problem, weil diese Bitcoins werden natürlich jetzt getainted und das bedeutet, dass du die in den meisten Exchanges äh werden sie die nicht mehr tauschen können, ne? Und wenn sie die irgendwo tauschen, sind die quasi,
nur unter starkem Verlust.
Tauschbar, weil alle wissen, dass das diese Bitcoins halt ähm ja an denen klebt, die Aufmerksamkeit der internationalen ähm Strafverfolgung, außer der russischen.
Okay, so also quasi die Rolle der und der kriminellen Banden, die sich jetzt also auch die natürlich über die Grenzen hinweg operiert haben. Das sind Menschen aus dem Internet. Ähm und jetzt hier offenbar auch,
persönlichen Zwist entwickeln und so weit so in Anführungszeichen.
Normal eigentlich, oder? Also das bis dahin war noch alles so ja
kennt man Russland begleitet seine Aktionen mit äh Infrastrukturangriffen, ja Russland hat äh seine kriminellen Banden. Gut, die die,
zoffen sich jetzt mal über diesen Konflikt und ähm,
liegen sich Ihre Daten, okay schon mal spannend, aber bisher noch nix äh unvorhergesehenes passiert.
Oder wie würdest du das sagen, Tim.
Ich meine, dass es die Gruppen gibt und dass die jetzt gegebenenfalls in diesen Konflikt auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise mit eingreifen, will ich jetzt nicht sonderlich überraschend. Ich meine, es mag welche geben, die sich
ausm Kriegsgeschäft und und und politischen ähm Strukturen am äh lieber komplett raushalten, aber mit Sicherheit hast du halt auch da so ein paar in Anführungsstrichen Patrioten,
der Meinung sind, sie müssten jetzt äh ihre Kräfte fürs Vaterland äh auch noch spielen lassen,
schwer abzuschätzen, ne. Auf jeden Fall sehen wir das ja in diesem Konti-Beispiel im im Widerstand, wo sicherlich die höhere Motivation äh herrscht. Kann mir also sehr gut vorstellen, dass das vor allem auf ukrainischer Seite ein,
motivierender Faktor sein könnte. Wie stark der jetzt in äh Russland oder Weißrussland ausgeprägt ist, keine Ahnung. Ich meine am Ende wollen die halt eigentlich äh nur reich werden.
Ähm ja ist nicht ganz so einfach, aber das sind zumindest schon mal alles ziemlich weit gekommen. Aber ja, aber das,
Problem ist natürlich, dass jetzt,
diese ganze Frage des IT-Kriegs ähm jetzt natürlich hier eine eine Rolle spielt und das auf dass es auf jeden Fall Gruppen gibt, die jetzt der Meinung sind, man müsse eben jetzt mit diesen,
vermeintlichen Fähigkeiten, die man hat,
in irgendeiner Form äh Russland schaden, damit sie irgendwie bestraft werden oder vielleicht sogar auch in irgendeiner Form ihren Fähigkeiten diesen Krieg zu führen, beschränkt werden, ne oder zumindest irgendwie
als öffentliches Signal hier äh aktiv zu werden, nicht? Und äh von daher,
überraschend, dass ähm es wieder der Name Anonymus ist, der hier kommt,
die ja äh eine lange Geschichte des selbst Aufplusterns haben,
und jetzt sich wieder in entsprechenden Verlautbarungen äh öffentlich äußern und sagen, hier äh wir müssen die freie Welt retten, wir kann es besser als wir, wir sind Anonymus, wir sind irgendwie besiegbar,
jetzt geht's los und alle müssen jetzt irgendwie äh mit anfangen und äh scharen ihre anonymen Truppen um sich, ne. Das ist so ein bisschen dieses Bild, was immer gerne gezeichnet wird.
Ja und da geschehen jetzt Dinge so, ne.
Und äh inwiefern die jetzt hilfreich sind, das das steht aufm anderen Blatt, aber da toben sich jetzt auf jeden Fall auch eine ganze Menge Leute aus und glauben ähm oder machen das zumindest im Namen eben dieses
Widerstands so ne ähm.
Vielleicht müssen wir nochmal ein und noch ein bisschen weiter vorne ansetzen, ja? Also hat ja haben nicht nur gesagt, wir greifen jetzt Russland, sondern wir gesagt, wir erklären Vladimir Putin jetzt den Cyber-Krieg.
Runter geht's natürlich nicht, ne?
Da drunter geht es nicht und ähm es ist erstaunlich
Also äh neunundzwanzig muss man vielleicht noch mal dazu sagen, auch zum Funktionieren dieses Kollektivs, ja. And Onomes ist eine ist eine Idee, ein Label, was man sich irgendwie schnappen kann. Ja und äh oder was,
man sich anschließen kann. Das ist jetzt keine feste Gruppierung, die haben nicht irgendwie einen Vereinsstammtisch oder sonst was. Aber jetzt ruft halt äh auf und sagt, wir erklären jetzt den äh Russland den Cyber-Krieg und motivieren eine ganze Menge Leute
dazu.
Da mitzumachen. Ähm die Aktionen, die dann da jetzt bisher zu sehen waren, waren die Nylon of Service-Angriffe auf alle möglichen Webseiten, die vorher niemand kannte.
Die auch entsprechend jetzt keine großartige haben wo man sagen muss das ist jetzt auch nicht so schwer eine eine Webseite,
zu ne also es gibt eine klare Schwelle an Bandbreite oder CPU-Ressourcen in dem Moment wo du die überschreitest äh ist das Ding nicht mehr erreichbar
fertig, ja? Hm solange das keine Webseite ist, die ähm die,
in dem Sinne kritisch ist, dass sie ähm pro Minute, die sie nicht online ist, Geld verliert oder ähm,
in irgendeiner Form Abhängigkeiten von ihr bestehen, die weitere stören, gibt sich auch eigentlich niemand die Mühe.
Ähm seine Webseite ernsthaft dagegen zu schützen, ja,
also beispielsweise jetzt der Metaebene Server der Logbuchnetzpolitik ausliefert, der muss äh bei der Veröffentlichung einer neuen Episode eine ganze Menge,
Witz und Bitesschaufeln, ja, aber äh ich denke nicht, dass es mir schwerfallen würde, den von hier zu Hause mit einer normalen Leitung oder vielleicht von einer,
von einem anderen Server aus einfach an seine Grenzen zu bringen, dass der niemanden mehr antwortet
ja? Das ist aber auch etwas, wogegen wir uns jetzt quasi nicht schützen, weil es mehr kosten würde, sich dagegen zu schützen als es kostet, wenn irgendein Spinner mal am Tag die Seite runter,
äh äh die die Seite überlastet, ja? Insofern die Nahe of Service-Angriffe sind jetzt kein kein kriegerischer Schaden. Wie gesagt, irgendwelche Webseiten, äh die keine Sau kennt,
oder die, die jetzt auch nicht irgendwie sinnvoll jemand besuchen möchte oder wo du jetzt auch nicht die Message änderst, weil sie nicht mehr erreichbar ist,
Du sagst einfach nur Tango-Down-Cremlin Punkt ist nicht mehr erreichbar. Gut.
Ganz Russland sitzt da und weiß nicht mehr, was sich im Internet anschauen soll, ne? Also der der Effekt ist der einer Sitzblockade, den darf man darf man jetzt auch nicht ähm,
unterschätzen in dem Sinne, ne? Das hat ja es kriegt ja seine Aufmerksamkeit. Aber ich sehe nicht wirklich nicht.
Das Vladimir Putin jetzt da sitzt und sagt Scheiße Günther ähm,
bin ich hier mit dem Panzer in der Ukraine und man kann meine schöne Webseite des Kreml nicht mehr äh angucken. Ich glaube, ich gebe auf, ne. Also das ist ja weit, weit gefehlt, dass dass das in irgendeiner Form mehr wäre als ein als ein Protest,
haben Sie irgendwelche Leaks veröffentlicht von, sagen wir im weitesten Sinne äußerst zweifelhafter Qualität.
Irgend so ein Link auf mega äh hatte ich zum Glück, also der war dann relativ schnell auch wieder weg. Äh hatte ich aber Glück, den noch runterzuladen. Äh da waren irgendwie also eine Textdatei mit ein paar,
paar Passwörtern für hm äh Müllpunkt, Ruh und Golfpunkt Ruh-Adressen drin, die jetzt aber auch irgendwie nicht glaubwürdig aussahen.
Und irgendein irgendeinen VLC-Player äh Paket, also irgendwelche also wirklich ähm.
Na ja also wirklich nix Ernstzunehmendes ne und ähm,
Habe mal geschaut, was ich für einfach nur bei mir in der Sammlung für Adressen von Mill und Goff Punkt Ruh habe. Da hätte ich aber spontan mehr gehabt als als die. Ähm
und wer wer wahrscheinlich glaubhafter gewesen, wenn man das äh veröffentlicht hätte, was auch schon uralt ist, ne.
Und jetzt äh spamen sie äh Restaurantbewertungen. Soweit so ähm militärisch harmlos.
Als ich möchte aber trotzdem wichtig, dass man mich hier nicht falsch versteht. Militärisch harmlos als Protestform,
durchaus anzuerkennen, ja ähm es ist ebenso militärisch harmlos, wenn sich in Berlin ähm viele tausend,
Menschen versammeln, um gegen den Angriffskrieg zu demonstrieren und die stehen auch keinem einzigen russischen Panzer im Weg. Trotzdem ist das wichtig, äh dass alle Menschen jetzt ihren,
ihren Beitrag leisten und ihre ihre Verzweiflung oder ihrer Wut oder auch ihrer Ablehnung und ihrem Protest Ausdruck verleihen. Ja und wenn das macht,
ist das auch in Ordnung. Ich halte das jetzt nicht für ähm besonders ähm.
Besonders zielführend, ja, also sage ich mal, wenn unter Kremlin Punkt Ruhr auf einmal eine eine Aufklärung darüber stünde, dass gerade ein Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine stattfindet. Das wäre da würde ich auf jeden Fall sehr viel bessere Haltungsnoten für geben, als wenn da einfach nur steht, Seite ist nicht erreichbar.
Aber das äh das dieser Eindruck, der da jetzt erweckt wird mit dem Begriff Cyber-Krieg und so weiter und der auch erstaunlich viele Menschen,
wirklich überzeugt hat ja also mich haben viele Leute angeschrieben und meinten so yo Linus bist du auch dabei ich hoffe ihr zeigt's dem Putin
oder ähm eine Freundin meiner Mutter hatte allen Ernstes,
so gesagt, dass also ihre Hoffnung ist, ist natürlich auch nur ein Ausdruck der Verzweiflung, muss man auch dazu sagen, ja. Dass ihre größte Hoffnung jetzt grade ernonimmes wäre.
Und dann weißt du natürlich, dass mit seiner PR da echt ein bisschen schiefgelaufen ist, wenn sie irgendwie.
Also nicht nur enorm ist, sondern auch mit der Verstärkung, die sie in den Medien erfahren haben, ne äh dass das wirklich ein bisschen schief gelaufen ist, dass jetzt ernsthaft ein paar Leute also Leute, ein paar Aktivisten.
Zutrauen in einem internationalen bewaffneten Konflikt eine entscheidende Rolle zu spielen.
Das ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen ein Zeichen der generellen Überschätzung,
der Möglichkeiten, die man so im Computerbereich hat, ne, weil so der Computer einfach von vielen Leuten und
die Netzwerke noch sehr viel mehr. Immer noch so als Wundermaschine wahrgenommen werden.
Was einfach damit zu tun hat, dass die meisten Leute eben die komplexe Technologie dieses Jahr letztlich auch darstellt, so in der Regel nicht vollständig verstehen.
Wer tut das schon? Das ne, dass dass dem dann immer auch so eine besondere Wirkmacht,
zugeschrieben wird oder dass zumindest sich das dann auch verbindet mit eben dieser Hoffnung, die äh jetzt so ein bisschen schwächelt aufgrund der allgemeinen Verzweiflung, in der wir uns eigentlich befinden. Weil wir haben,
nicht kommen sehen,
Klar, es gab Leute, die haben's kommen sehen, aber die hat ja dann keiner zugehört. Jeder hat bis zum Schluss noch gedacht, na ja, wenn ich jetzt lange noch die Augen zuhalte, dann wird's schon nicht passieren und dann passiert's halt trotzdem,
Jetzt äh schlägt das natürlich dann auch in null Komma nix um in Angst vor,
dem nuklearen Thermoklearen äh Krieg, der äh alles platt machen wird so. Das ist halt so eighties äh all over again so.
Ähm kenne das ja noch, wie das so damals so war, ne? Also so dieses Gefühl in Deutschland zu leben, so im am
am Grenzpunkt der des des kalten Krieges wurde irgendwie weiß, so wenn's wenn's jetzt morgen losgeht mit den Atomraketen, dann sind wir die Ersten, die komplett pulverisiert werden,
hat ja zu einigen interessanten kulturellen äh Auswüchsen auch geführt.
Später dann auch zu den goldenen Achtzigern natürlich, ne? Klar. Und.
Wann waren die denn? Also auf den Bildern sieht das aber nicht so aus. Die haben die sehen alle ganz traurig aus.
Maueröffnung?
Na ja okay gut. Die goldenen Achtziger. Im November.
Na ja, das ging schon los mit mit den neuen Deutschen Welle und so weiter.
Also okay, aber der Mauerfall war neunundachtzig. Also wenn das die goldenen Zwanziger sind, von denen du die ganze Zeit redest, Tim, ne, die wenn die irgendwie im Jahr 29 beginnen, ne, da bin ich aber echt ein bisschen.
Zwanziger sind Zwanziger. Das kann man jetzt nicht. Du kannst jetzt nicht irgendwie die Schlussjahre gegenüber die Anfangsjahren diskriminieren. Die gehören genauso zu den Dekade dazu wie alle anderen auch.
Er hat's halt an eine unbedeutende Minderheit jetzt der Zwanziger.
Na ja, lustig wurde schon vorher. Auf jeden Fall,
was ich sagen will ist, dass dass es so eine Angst, die natürlich jetzt viele haben. So und die jeder wahrscheinlich auch von uns gehabt hat, ne so und oh Gott Scheiße, was kommt da jetzt auf uns zu, ne? Und ähm natürlich,
dann viele Leute auch äh ihren,
ihre Hoffnungen an das was sie vielleicht am wenigsten einschätzen können. Was das meiste Mystikpotential äh noch hat und da gehört dieser ganze IT-Bereich natürlich ohne Zweifel auch mit dazu.
Ja. Es es aber übrigens auch, das ist nicht gut, dass du das gerade ansprichst. Auch,
im Rahmen äh der Sorge, ja? Also hm ohne jetzt zu viel zu sagen, ich wäre im Beruf der im Bereich der IT-Sicherheit tätig. Und da gibt es jetzt auch schon einige Nervosität.
Ja
Zeit wird's.
Äh genau, das das ist das kannst du natürlich dann nicht sagen. Das sagst du Leute hättet ihr euch vorher überlegen müssen. Aber das äh sagen wir natürlich auch nicht und in diesem Bereich äh äh,
wie gesagt sage ich jetzt nichts zur Arbeit. Es gibt's natürlich durchaus jetzt äh erhöhte Aufmerksamkeit, dass einem da äh ähm jetzt nicht was passiert und ähm in dem Bereich der großen.
Ähm also der der relevanten Infrastrukturen,
Und im Bereich des Finanzwesens würde ich jetzt durchaus sagen, dass da eine gewisse Aufmerksamkeit
nicht unbedingt so verkehrt ist ja vor allem in Anbetracht der ähm,
der äh finanziellen ähm Schläge gegen äh Russland, die gerade stattfinden, ja.
Ähm aber das jetzt äh also wie in dem Buch von ähm,
hieß der Elsberg ja ne, Daniel Elsberg, Blackout äh wie dort beschrieben ähm,
dass es jetzt zu einem monatelangen Ausfall äh oder zu einem zu einem messbar langen Ausfall von äh kritischer Infrastruktur in Deutschland kommt
durch
Cyber-Krieg halte ich für äußerst unwahrscheinlich, vor allem wenn man sich überlegen muss, dass es irgendwo in Russland ein großes Rad an einer an einem sehr dicken Rohr gibt, an dem man einfach dreht und wir haben ganz andere Infrastrukturprobleme innerhalb kürzester Zeit, ne.
Also.
Mark Elsberg meinst du.
Mark Elsberg sorry.
Morgen ist es zu spät, ein Roma.
Genau, das ist äh dieses äh äh Buch, was schon vor vielen Jahren erschienen ist und äh quasi einmal ähm ja,
sagen technisch realistisch äh erklärt, wie man durch äh Hacking längere Zeit zu einem Ausfall des Stromnetzes in Europa äh ähm beitragen könnte.
Dann gibt's außerdem den Vortrag auch schon etwas älter aufm Kongress hier von äh Matthias Dahlheimer. Ähm so,
wie man einen Blackout verursachen kann und warum das dann doch nicht so einfach ist. Ja, der also noch mal ein bisschen die technischen Hintergründe ähm da erklärt. Ähm.
Sind aber noch bei diesen Sachen. Müssen wir noch mal kurz zurück. Ich habe eingangs gesagt, es ist wenn du wirklich wirksam.
Infrastrukturen langfristig stören möchtest, ja? Dafür musst du,
ein sehr gutes Verständnis davon haben, wie die funktionieren und im Zweifelsfall die bereits infiltriert haben.
Ja, also im Prinzip Auskundschaften. Wie wie geht das hier und dich bis an den Punkt
Auskundschaft, wo du weißt, okay, wenn ich jetzt hier etwas mache, sorge ich für eine Störung und dann möchtest du natürlich eigentlich auch eine Störung, wenn du jetzt militärischer Akteur bist. Eine Störung herbeiführen, die nicht nur 12 oder 24 Stunden ist,
sondern potenziell,
richtig, richtig problematisch, ne? Dafür musst du sehr verstanden haben, äh wie das System funktioniert. Vielleicht auch zum Beispiel was für Kontingenzpläne ist für dieses System,
Insofern halte ich es für sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass jemand, der vor einer Woche begonnen hat.
In den Cyberkrieg zu ziehen jetzt relevante Infrastruktur in Russland nachhaltig stört,
Es ist aber nicht auszuschließen, dass es irgendjemanden gelingt. Wir haben ja sehr äh,
motivierte und sehr kluge Leute äh unter den Hackern. Das wäre natürlich, also dieser sehr unwahrscheinliche Fall.
Wäre aber auch sicherlich äußerst unschön, denn Russland würde darauf mit einer militärischen Logik reagieren,
und die mit dieses Problem von Infrastrukturangriffen, Cyberangriffen ist, man kann sie nicht attribuieren so einfach, man wird nicht spontan, da steht nicht dran, das war jetzt hier
oder so was, ne? Steht ja nicht dran. Und die Leute versuchen ja auch äh ne ihre Herkunft zu verschleiern. Das heißt mit Russland würde sehr einfach einen derartigen Angriff verantwortlich machen, wen sie möchten.
Und das ist natürlich ein Gedanke, bei dem vielen unwohl wird.
Wenn jetzt durch eine Cyberware Rhetorik von ein paar äh Aktivisten die.
Solange man das als politischen Protest bezeichnet, ähm.
Interessante aufmerksamkeitserregende und erfolgreiche Aktion durchführen, aber sobald man sie in einen militärischen Kontext setzt.
Einfach mal ein bisschen außerhalb ihrer Kragenweite sind. Ähm und da kann man natürlich schon sich Szenarien vorstellen, die ähm.
Äußerst ungünstig wären, ja. Wie gesagt, ich halte das Eintreten noch für relativ unwahrscheinlich, aber wir haben.
Ganze Menge für unwahrscheinlich gehalten und das wäre glaube ich kein also ich kann mir keine Situation vorstellen, in der,
irgendeine nicht äh militärisch diplomatisch und sonst wie geschulte Person.
Jetzt meint, in einen Krieg zu ziehen und irgendwelche Infrastrukturen in einem anderen Land angreifen zu müssen, während dieser Krieg grade das Thema ist, was die Welt beschäftigt. Also das das äh da kann ich echt nur sagen
die Finger weg. Glücklicherweise haben hoffentlich alle die technisch in der Lage sind solche Angriffe durchzuführen, sich diese Gedanken schon,
Vor langer Zeit gemacht, warum sie das nicht tun und äh ihre Fähigkeiten anders zum Einsatz bringen.
Aber ich meine so vom allgemeinen Absicherung der Infrastruktur sage ich mal ist jetzt nicht ausgeschlossen, dass ähm.
Dass da ein ähm äh junges, junger Mensch äh auch spontan sehr viel äh Hacking-Erfolg äh,
hat und wer dann wirklich sehr schlecht beraten da zu meinen eine Infrastruktur angreifen zu müssen.
Ja, also das ist natürlich generell, das ist natürlich auch etwas, was man was man abwägen muss, ne. Also man geht ein individuelles Risiko ein und man geht äh auch ein kollektives Risiko ein. Beides ist schwierig in seiner Bedrohung,
einzuschätzen,
also in der Bedrohung für einen selbst oder für für das äh Kollektiv, was man meint zu vertreten. Ja, also kann kann persönliche Sanktionen nach sich ziehen, das kann eben aber auch vor allem,
Ne, man könnte natürlich jetzt auch argumentieren, na ja, ein Putin äh wenn der eine Ausrede braucht für einen Cyber-Angriff, so, dann ist er auch in der Lage, die selber sich auszudenken.
Das stimmt natürlich, das ist das ist natürlich absolut richtig.
Ähm es es sei denn äh diese Aktion hätte jetzt tatsächlich einen,
unerfassbaren Erfolg. Also wenn man jetzt sagen,
oh, auf einmal wird jetzt die ganze äh militärische Commandstruktur äh hinter der Frontlinie äh außer Gefecht gesetzt durch irgend so einen IT-Angriff, was für eher unwahrscheinlich halte, ja? Aber sagen wir mal so was.
Halte ich für ausgeschlossen, Tim.
Das halte ich jetzt auch für ausgeschlossen, aber ich will's nur mal.
Den Leuten auch einfach mal vermitteln, dass also das also ganz klar, ich sage es jetzt hier nochmal ganz klar, dass,
irgendeiner vom jetzt irgendwie die,
Wehrfähigkeit oder die Angriffsfähigkeit Russlands und die Möglichkeit, einen Krieg aufrechtzuerhalten, mit Panzern und Bomben empfindlich stört, ist.
Wirklich ein äußerst schlimm, äußerst schmaler Wahrscheinlichkeitsbereich.
Gut, aber jetzt kann man nochmal
es könnte man auch noch mal einen potenziellen positiven Aspekt dieser Aktion auch nochmal mit ins Spiel reinrühren, ne, so weil wir sehen ja auch, dass äh
neben der reinen militärischen äh Realität, die dieser Krieg bisher entfacht hat. Der läuft jetzt seit einer Woche ungefähr. Warte mal, ja,
Donnerstag genau vor einer Woche und ähm,
Natürlich ist jetzt der Skien Waffen macht relativ wenig erst mal entgegen zu also,
Klar, es gibt auch da Erfolge. Wir wollten ja jetzt hier nicht über über äh
über das, was jetzt on the battleground äh tatsächlich stattfindet, spekulieren da wissen wir jetzt zu wenig drüber oder es ist auch nicht unser Feld. Aber es gibt ja noch einen zweiten Lehrer, der auch stattfindet und das ist eben dieser mediale,
wie wird dieser Konflikt.
In der Ukraine, in Russland und weltweit gesehen, bewertet und letzten Endes, was es sozusagen auch das.
Bild, was ich davon einprägt, was was sozusagen was bestimmt die Hirne, was was wer hat quasi die die Vormachtstellung,
bezüglich der Botschaft, wer jetzt hier Bösewicht ist oder oder eben Recht ist. Und da kann man schon sagen
die Ukraine an der Stelle äh sehr viel besser aufgestellt ist als auf dem Schlachtfeld derzeit. Und natürlich könnten, könnten solche
Aktion vielleicht auch dazu beitragen
ähnlich wie du schon gesagt hast, 00.000 Leute in Berlin, jetzt auch keinen unmittelbaren Einfluss haben, aber die Bilder und die Botschaft, die damit verbunden ist
ja die ja sowohl in die deutsche Gesellschaft selber reinstrahlt, weil man
quasi auf einmal auf der Straße steht und sieht, ah okay, die Sicht, die ich habe, teilen sehr viele andere Leute auch und hier sind definitiv zehn, fünfzehn, 20 Mal so viele Leute wie bei der letzten Querdenker-Demo, scheint also dann doch ein bisschen relevanter zu sein. Ähm
aber es strahlt ja auch in die Ukraine zurück, in Form von Solidarität,
wir werden nicht allein gelassen äh unser unsere Anstrengung uns dem entgegenzustellen, so schwer es eben auch ist, wird zumindest auch äh,
gedeckt und und und unterstützt. Könnte sein. Ob's den Aufwand und das Risiko wert ist, ist schwer abzuschätzen. Aber eher halt nicht.
Ja also ich denke man muss da einfach mal die Sachen äh realistisch einschätzen und ähm
was da grade passiert ist, ist äh eine große Tragik auf äh ganz fürchterlicher Ebene und ähm ich sehe da jetzt äh
Wie gesagt, habe sehr viel
Sympathie für den politischen Protest und auch die Aktionsformen aber das sind einen militärischen Kontext zu tragen halte ich für
äh sehr sehr falsch. Ne, also auch insbesondere eben mit so Bildern, dass jetzt Leute sagen, sie meinen, dass das jetzt,
Russland nennenswert schwächen würde, ne, zumal äh wir ja beide äh ohne Experten zu sein uns gerade eher auch darüber Sorgen machen, dass der,
ähm sage ich mal der Weg zum Frieden vermutlich irgendeine ähm.
Irgendein Angebot des Gesichtswarens für Putin beinhalten muss.
Und damit also letztendlich auf der diplomatischen Ebene und nicht auf der zerstörerischen Ebene liegt.
Glaubst du? Also.
Ich sehe nicht, wie du jemanden also ähm.
Ich sehe nicht, wie der sein Gesicht noch wahren kann oder dass er überhaupt an der Wahrung.
Genau das Problem.
Noch äh ein Interesse hat. Also ich glaube, dass hier wirklich äh rein militärische Logik am Ende eine Rolle spielen wird.
Umso wichtiger, dass er als Aktivisten dich da nicht äh
nicht mit rein begriffst, ehrlich gesagt. Aber Tim, du hast gesagt, wir wollten und das finde ich auch sehr wichtig, nochmal das Fenster ein bisschen weiter aufmachen und auch mal überhaupt auf Aktivismus blicken.
Ja, das ist so ein ist ja so ein Begriff, der aufkam. Ich habe jetzt,
gerade versucht nachzuschlagen, wann das war, aber das ist mal wieder so eine Präp und Prä Wikipedia Geschichte und wir wissen ja alles, was irgendwie vor der Wikipedia war, ist erstmal nicht relevant, ne? Ähm,
Aber als das so losging mit dem Netz so und ähm ich glaube das muss so sechsundneunzig oder irgendwie so was gewesen sein.
Da hat dann äh Frankreich ja noch Atomtests durchgeführt. Ähm boah toll.
Im Südpazifik und.
Wie man sich vorstellen kann, gab's da ein gewissen äh Widerstand und das war dann eben so die Zeit, wo es schon so diese ersten.
Wie soll ich sagen, wo das Netz kulturell das erste Mal sichtbar war, ne? Es war so dieses frühe Web,
erst seit äh ein paar Jahren existierte und es war so die ersten zwei Jahre des ersten Hypes waren so gerade so durch.
Sprich man hat das so wahrgenommen und ne, da war ja noch diese ganze Zukunftseuphorie zweitausend und so und natürlich alle Leute, die sich im Web
tummelt haben oder die sich überhaupt im Netz getummelt hatten, hatten halt auch noch so diese ja diese Vision von wir sind jetzt hier die Zukunft und
ne, das Internet wird in Frieden bringen, weil jetzt können wir ja alle miteinander kommunizieren und wenn die ganze Welt sich erst mal unterhalten kann, dann werden wir uns auch alle verstehen und alles wird gut und so. Gut, haben wir ja gesehen, was dabei rausgekommen ist. Ein bisschen schwierig.
Auf jeden Fall aus der Zeit gab's dann eben auch,
diese Aktivität das erste Mal dass man der Meinung war man müsste eben jetzt den Protest auch ins Netz tragen und dieses ganze diese ganze Vorstellung mit ähm dem,
in die Kniezwingen von Webservern, also Dedos-Attacken, wurde da geboren. Und dem wurde dann in dem Zuge auch dieser Begriff hectivisum,
zugeschrieben. Der kam halt auf einmal auf, ne und
Klar, es scheint ja erst mal naheliegend zu sein, so ja das ist ja Aktivismus, ne? Man kämpft ja hier für die gute Sache. Man macht das irgendwie im Netz und jetzt jetzt äh äh macht man da so Server kaputt oder schaltet irgendwie Dienstleistungen aus?
Hacker, ne? So dann wurden einfach diese beiden Worte äh zusammengeworfen und dann dann wurde das so so aus dem Nichts heraus zu so einem stehenden Begriff.
Aber keiner so richtig eigentlich mit Inhalt füllen konnte, weil dafür war es einfach auch noch viel zu früh.
Ich erinnere mich noch, wie wir die Diskussion auch im Club hatten darum und äh das eigentlich relativ schnell,
die äh Grundhaltung aufkamen, dass das nix für uns ist und dass wir einfach äh vom Zerstören Infrastrukturen,
nix halten, ne, also dass das einfach äh keine keine gute Idee ist, darüber einen äh Protest zu führen, ne? Jetzt kann man natürlich argumentieren,
inwiefern so was äh eigentlich nur eine digitale Sitzblockade ist, weil da geht ja die Straße auch nicht bald kaputt.
Der Server, der kann ja danach auch wieder angeschaltet werden, ne? Das ist ja nur die Dienstleistung, die für einen kurzen Moment weg war,
Ja, ne? Das war so ist so die eine Sichtweise. Die andere Sichtweise haben wir ja eben auch schon diskutiert. Ist ja, dass solche äh,
ja auch Folgen haben können, ne, dass dann eben tatsächlich dahinterliegende Infrastrukturen ähm ausgeschaltet werden, was dann,
keine Ahnung, irgendwelche wilden Konsequenzen auch für für Dritte haben kann, weil Stromausfall, keine Ahnung, was auch immer dann äh passieren kann.
Und später gab's ja auch solche richtigen Hacker-Attacken, ne, wo eben gezielt die Geheimdienste mit äh solchen Maßnahmen eben versucht haben äh und auch wohl erfolgreich waren im Iran äh irgendwelche äh Atomanlagen zu,
sabotieren.
Deswegen ist dieser Begriff schlecht definiert und eigentlich hat sich bis heute da auch so recht keinen Konsens für mich raus geschält, wie man das äh handhabt oder auch nur bezeichnen soll,
letzten Jahren hat halt einfach Anonymus mit seinem Gehabe hier im Wesentlichen da die Litfaßsäulen vollgemalt und so ein bisschen für sich so in Anspruch genommen,
diese Art von Protestkultur zu repräsentieren, zusammen eben mit diesem ganzen,
verschwurbelten Widerstandsgedanken und diesem Guy Forks Masken und diesem ganzen Quatsch der da noch mit äh,
dranhängt, ja und man weiß auch nie so genau, okay, wer definiert denn da jetzt eigentlich die politische Ausrichtung und was jetzt sozusagen angemessen ist, ja, also,
okay ist alles irgendwie total super anonym und so und keiner äh äh tritt da so nach vorne. Heißt aber auch, dass dass du auch keinerlei Accountability hast und dass du eigentlich auch
gar keine klare Positionierung hast, was du jetzt gut findest oder nicht. Ja so Ukrainekrieg, okay, alles klar, da kann man sich jetzt äh drüber
hinter versammeln so, aber was wäre denn, wenn anderen die muss jetzt irgendwie äh für Russland dann auf einmal irgendwie in den Krieg zieht,
Was ist dann? Ist es das, ist das dann dann auch gut so? Ja, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Also äh finde das also,
ich möchte einfach nochmal wiederholen, wenn wir jetzt von Kriegerischen Auseinandersetzungen sprechen, so. Dann sind wir einfach mal weit außerhalb der Liga von Enonimus.
Es ist einfach so. Du du kriegst nicht,
das wäre der der Fall von ähm blindes Huhn findet ein Korn, wenn die irgendwo was wirklich ähm äh kaputt machen können
ich meine, die konzentrieren sich momentan auf Dedos-Angriffe. Das ist etwas, das kannst du kannst du kaufen, kannst du klicken, kannst du mit Java-Script machen. Ja, das soll nicht heißen, dass da nicht auch Leute bei sind, die nennenswerte Fähigkeiten haben, aber der Organisationsgrad
den notwendig ist, um eine strukturierte äh um strukturierten Angriff zu machen. Der kann nicht ad hoc gemacht werden, der kann erst recht nicht mit anonymen äh Zusammenschlüssen gemacht werden
ein Teil, den wir jetzt gerade ganz außen vor gelassen haben, sorry ist, dass ja auch die die Ukraine,
ich weiß gar nicht, welcher Minister das war, der dann da getwittert hat wir haben jetzt wir gründen jetzt ad hoc die ukrainische Cyberarmee.
Folgender Telegram-Gruppe. Also das wäre mir wirklich der erste Fall.
Der mir einfällt, dass ich äh in dem Fall sind ja, ich glaube, als ich letztes Mal geguckt habe, in Richtung dreihunderttausend Leute da drin, in dieser Telegram-Gru,
Und da machen sie die ganzen Tag irgendwie jetzt die Webseite wupp die du und Tango down und äh kommen sich dann davor, als hätten sie jetzt irgendjemanden irgendwas gemacht, was irgendjemand interessiert?
Ich wehre mich wirklich dagegen den irgendwie eine zu hohe äh zu hohe Bedeutung im militärischen Bereich zu zu,
sortieren. Muss ich wirklich, also ich und ich hoffe, die nimmt jetzt nicht persönlich, aber äh um um solche derartige Dinge zu tun, brauchst du halt wirklich Infrastruktur, Vertrauen, ähm leises Vorgehen und keine Telegram-Gruppe,
Ja, also ich meine.
Sag mal so, ich habe schon den ein oder anderen Hack abgebrochen, weil ich aus Versehen zu viel drüber gesprochen hatte. Ja, da würde ich jetzt nicht in einer Telegram-Gruppe ankündigen, wie ich hacke.
So das äh ich sehe halt wirklich nicht, dass sie in diesem Bereich irgendwo in der Nähe von,
von kombatanten sind von dem was sie tun, von dem was sie wie sie reden auf jeden Fall und das ist äh ist nicht klug.
Da ist äh glaube ich kein Blumentopf äh zu holen und da tut sich auch glaube ich die Ukraine nicht unbedingt ein Gefallen, auch wenn sie natürlich,
verständlich. Also ich kann dieses Gefühl,
der äh wir holen uns jede Hilfe, die wir kriegen können, kann ich irgendwie verstehen. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich an der Stelle genauso wenig hilfreich, wie äh dieser Ruf nach ähm,
ausm Ausland. Ja, das wird zahlenmäßig nie den Unterschied machen und das sind dann Zweifelsfalle auch eher problematische oder vollkommen untaugliche Leute.
Die sie dann äh dort bekommen, ne.
Ähm was übrigens auch noch ein Aspekt ist, der ähm in diesem Kontext ja auch noch mal eine Rolle spielt mhm.
Also.
Gut allgemeine äh Verunsicherung herrscht und ähm man sorgt sich jetzt um äh den Cyberkrieg.
Nach meiner, also zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt betrachte ich diese Sorge als halbwegs noch unwahrscheinlich.
Aber natürlich relativ schnell in den begründbaren Bereich sich begeben. Und dann überlegt man sich, wann machen wir denn dann?
Und das finde ich übrigens auch spannend, dass da sehr äh ja, sagen wir mal, ich glaube falsche Vorstellungen herrschen.
Also was wären zu erwartende ähm.
Effekte oder Angriffsziele eines äh Cyber-Kriegs. Ja im Zweifelsfall.
Angriffe auf ähm ja kritische Infrastrukturen, aber meine vorsichtige These wäre, nicht irgendwie oder nicht notwendigerweise Stromwasser.
Sondern ich würde eher also meine mein Gedanke wäre eher so ja Finanzsystem oder so ne erschüttern wir mal äh die Börse ja lassen wir da mal richtig was rasseln ähm,
was weiß ich, wird
kann ein paar Tage nicht gehandelt werden. Absolute die ganzen Kapitalisten, denen alles gehört, äh werden nervös. Ja, wir wir erschüttern die top one percent. In Russland nennt man die äh Uli Garchen bei uns. Ähm
erfolgreiche Manager oder so was, ne, oder Investoren. So denen mal richtig Angst machen. So, das wäre halt äh äh,
so das, was ich mir vorstellen könnte, ja? Ähm.
Und dann sagt man ja, jetzt brauchen wir aber eine eine Freiwilligenarmee, die dann äh zurück hackt,
und so ein Quatsch also Hackback haben wir jetzt hier wirklich oft genug bequatscht, dass das ein absoluter Unsinn ist, ja also absolutes Hirngespinst
dann geht's nur darum bei dieser Debatte selber offensive Fähigkeiten zu bekommen. Ähm aber auch,
Also sagen wir mal, hier würde jetzt längere Zeit etwas ausfallen. Wer muss sich denn kümmern? Sagen wir mal.
Hypothetisches Beispiel, wie gesagt, ich halte es nicht für realistisch, aber das wird jetzt diskutiert. In Berlin, dreieinhalb Millionen Einwohner.
Äh Stromausfall oder Wasserausfall. So wer wird dieses Problem am Ende lösen? Die,
Wasserexperten, die Stromexpertinnen.
Oder die Hacking-Expertin. Es werden natürlich die Leute das Problem am Ende tatsächlich lösen, die diese Infrastrukturen verstanden haben.
Und ihre Notsysteme bedienen können. Ja, das heißt, ähm wenn er jetzt häufig so gesagt wird, wir brauchen aber die Leute, die Ahnung vom Hucking haben
Ich glaube, dass das auch überschätzt wird der Bedarf, abgesehen davon, dass er so oder so der Bedarf sehr schnell die Ressourcen überschreiten würde und ich glaube, dass das nicht ganz so schlimm ist, wie man es sich vorstellen würde,
Ähm also ne, Strom.
Am Ende stellen den Kram die Leute wieder her, die wissen, wie's funktioniert. Und ich bin ja durchaus auch in der Inzidentresponse tätig und kann sagen, dass ich da ohne die Expertise derer, die diese Infrastrukturen ähm betreiben.
Nie nennenswert weit gekommen wäre. Ich kann da höchstens an deren Seite stehen. Denen helfen den Prozess zu strukturieren. Den,
helfen zu verstehen, wovon sie ausgehen müssen bei dem Compromis, welchen warum sie bestimmten Systemen nicht vertrauen können und in welcher Reihenfolge wir uns wieder eine IT-Infrastruktur schaffen, der wir vertrauen können, aber gerade diese Versorgungsinfrastrukturen
sind ja also dafür haben wir ja Notsysteme,
also was weiß ich, hier fällt jetzt ein kein Strom im Krankenhaus, dann haben die erstmal so und so viel Liter Diesel im Keller. In der Zeit kannst du da Aggregate hinstellen. Deswegen müsste
um's wirklich katastrophal zu machen, dieser Infrastrukturausfall eben auch sehr lang seien. Und das ich,
da jetzt irgendwie eine äh Freiwilligenarmee aus Verteidigern und so was herbeizuführen, sehe ich alles. Erstens kurzfristig sowieso nicht möglich,
Also weil die Ressourcen einfach gar nicht da sind, egal wie viele Leute du jetzt spontan in die freiwillige Cyber-Abwehr,
der Ukraine begibst, wirst du nicht schnell genug.
Die Spreu vom Weizen trennen und ein Organisationsgrad herstellen können, dass sie irgendeinen nennenswerten Beitrag leisten können. Also ne das geht einfach also ad hoc Leute versammeln kannst du ähm,
am Bahnhof, damit sie die Geflüchteten in den Sonderzügen entgegennehmen.
Oder ähm was gerade Menschen auch wirklich an wichtigen Dingen tun, dass sie, ne, benötigtes Sammeln, Familien unterbringen und so was. Das kannste ad hoc mit vielen Leuten machen, aber eine kritische Infrastruktur wieder aufbauen. Das machen am besten einfach die, die diese kritische Infrastruktur
verstanden haben. Insofern glaube ich tatsächlich, dass das ähm fundamentale.
Falsch Vorstellungen eigentlich sind, die da äh vorherrschen und mir ist,
gleichzeitig schaden sie ja eigentlich auch nicht. Geben den Leuten wenigstens was zu tun, ne.
Ja, also ich will auch gar nicht unterstellen, dass da nicht viel Goodwill vorherrscht, dass also Leute auch äh glauben, damit wirklich was Positives zu bewirken und sich nicht nur irgendwie da aufplustern wollen.
Immerhin machen sie's ja auch anonym,
ja? Also man hat ja sozusagen persönlich nichts davon im Sinne von ich zeige mal wie wie toll ich bin, sondern man geht da im Kollektiv auf. Von daher ist das sicherlich bei vielen auch so eine Motivation,
ich denke wenn man IT-Expertise wirklich hat dann gibt's auch andere Möglichkeiten sich da einzubringen also
sicherlich genug Bedarf, inwiefern man dann jetzt konkret äh der Ukraine helfen kann, bei all den Problemen, die das mit sich bringt, Sprache äh ne Kulturraum, Kenntnisse, Kontakte et cetera. Es ist ja nicht nicht ohne Weiteres möglich.
Probieren kann man's natürlich trotzdem mal, wenn man diese Ressourcen übrig hat.
Ähm ja, aber ich denke, das generell dieses Activism Feld problematisch ist und ja,
Jetzt wiederholen wir uns eigentlich auch nur. So ist es halt.
Aspekt gehen.
Ja hast du denn dein also du hast ja du hast ja letzten nicht letztes Mal aber als wir letztes Mal darüber gesprochen haben hast du ja äh auch gesagt ne die Kurse können auch wieder steigen ne beim beim Bitcoin und so weiter.
Habe ich Recht gehabt.
Hast du, hast du auch gekauft, hast du auch angelegt, hast du hast du darauf gewettet? Bist du jetzt.
Ich glaube meine also ich kann mit Bitcoin immer nur im Plus sein aber.
Also es müsste der Bitcoin müsste ziemlich tief fallen, damit ich dafür da wirklich finanziell im Minus bin. Weil echtes Geld habe ich da wenig drin. Ähm.
Rheinmetall-Aktien habe ich leider nicht. Da werden wir auch ein bisschen zu schmuddelig gewesen, muss ich.
Mhm ja.
Rheinmetall Outperforms Bitcoin ich würde sagen Rheinmetall hodeln Alter.
Okay, Spaß beiseite. Ähm wer halt äh extrem profitiert hat vom Kriegseintritt, ist der Bitcoin äh Kurs und das geht natürlich dann wieder für diese ganze Krypto-Charincy.
Der so krass profitiert? Nein.
Na ja, plus 25 Prozent würde ich mal sagen, plus zwanzig irgendwie, ist schon.
Nee. Ist es so schwer?
Na ja, also am 24.2. vor einer Woche, als es irgendwie losging, war so bei dreißig.700 Euro und äh.
Nee, nee, nee. Also guck dir mal auf einen Monat an, der äh oder also wenn du auf.
Mir das jetzt nicht auf den Monat an, ich gucke mir das jetzt auf eine Woche an und äh.
Ja gut, aber das ist eine ganz normale Bitcoin-Woche, Tim.
Ja, ich weiß es doch. Es ist halt,
Es ist nun mal genau so, ja. Mit Kriegsbeginn ging der Kurs hoch. So um knapp 20 Prozent,
dass das alles super volatil ist und nächste Woche schon wieder anders aussehen kann und dass es irgendwie auch nicht das erste Mal ist, dass dass solche äh extremen Ausschläge stattgefunden haben und das ist genauso auch morgen wieder fuffzig Prozent nach unten gehen kann,
klar und das haben wir hier auch schon mehrfach besprochen, nur so ist es. Und äh es ist halt auch interessant zu sehen, wie halt in dieser äh Kryptogate,
Blase jetzt hier mit dem Konflikt umgegangen wird, ist natürlich extrem äh vielfältig. Aber auf jeden Fall gibt's natürlich dann gleich wieder auch so diese ganze Debatte mit
äh was ist denn jetzt hier mit den äh Sanktionen, ne? Du hast ja vorhin gesagt, ja aber wie ist denn das hier mit einem Angriff und so auf die Börse, damit man die Kurse runtergehen,
wenn einem sowas gelingen würde,
Kurse würden danach auch schnell wieder hoch gehen. Jetzt hat allerdings die äh der russische Aktienindex, also dieser RTS,
der ähm das sieht gar nicht gut aus, ne? Den gibt's irgendwie erst seit zwanzig16 und der ist jetzt in den letzten Tagen halt genau wieder auf,
gefallen und äh ich glaube da ist auch relativ wenig Potential dafür, dass sich das auch bald wieder äh erholt.
Sprich die Finanz.
Sanktionen, die jetzt weltweit eingeleitet wurden, die ja erheblich sind und glaube ich weitergehen als,
alle der westlichen Gemeinschaft so zugetraut haben.
Ne, also gerade im Hinblick da drauf, dass Putzen ja bisher immer alles durch äh gegangen lassen wurde und ähm das jetzt eben nicht der Fall war und dabei ist gar nicht mal diese Einschränkung der Nutzung des Swift-Systems im Vordergrund, was ja jetzt
tagelang in den Medien immer als ja das das schärfste Schwert und so weiter ne äh stellt sich raus, das war gar nicht der schärfste Schwert, die äh haben erstens noch sehr viel andere äh Schwerter am Start und die haben auch durchaus,
brauchbare Trennschärfe. Ich glaube, der härteste äh Schnitt war, dass halt einfach auch die.
Die ganze also ist quasi auch die ganze russische Zentralbank blockiert wird und sämtliche im Ausland liegenden Vermögenswerte der Russen ähm blockiert wurden
Das ist halt einerseits allein was äh in Teilnehmenden Staaten so liegt, macht glaube ich schon mal allein,
wenn es nichts Falsches sagen, aber sowas in der Größenordnung von von 25 bis 30 Prozent des des äh der russischen Rücklagen aus. So und wir reden jetzt hier von insgesamt um die 640 Milliarden,
US-Dollar im Wert
und ähm natürlich können auch die Goldreserven, die sie haben, nicht ohne Weiteres jetzt in die Wiesen umgesetzt werden. Also das ist wirklich äh eine eine extreme Begrenzung. Und natürlich jetzt diese ganzen Investitions äh Beschränkungen und ähm der Abzug der Unternehmen,
das trifft halt jetzt Russland hart,
Aber eben auch dieses dieses Swift-Geschichte, weil's eben den Unternehmen unmöglich gemacht wird in irgendeiner Form noch Handel zu betreiben weltweit.
Und nur dadurch kommt natürlich die.
Noch machen jetzt oder nicht, Tim.
Ja, na ja, das ist natürlich jetzt sozusagen sofort die Erzählung, die dann die dann beginnt, ne.
Du Tim, ich bin froh, dass ich äh im Zweifelsfall wenn alle Infrastruktur am Boden liegt mit Bitcoin noch beim Bäcker bezahlen kann, ne?
Ja schön wär's ne. Also,
Tatsächlich also dieser steigende Kurs ist natürlich auch wieder nur ein Hype. Alles ist nur ein Hype in dieser Krypto-Geld äh Geschichte. So nur überlegen wir jetzt mal ganz kurz, was da eigentlich konkret passiert oder passieren könnte.
Zunächst einmal ist es halt so,
Es leiden halt jetzt sowohl die Unternehmen als auch der Staat als solcher und eben natürlich auch die Privatperson, ne. Viele Leute haben dann noch irgendwie versucht, Geld äh umzutauschen et cetera
oder überhaupt auch nur Geld abzuheben und das wird jetzt irgendwie schwierig. Der Rubel verfällt, hat irgendwie schon 30 Prozent Kursverlust, das wird wahrscheinlich,
besser werden und äh über kurz oder lang ähm ja,
Alle Kreditkarten funktionieren nicht mehr. Ja, jetzt jetzt bilden sich lange Schlangen in der U-Bahn, weil irgendwie ja ihre Apple Watch, kein Apple Pay mehr macht, alle Kreditkarten sind gesperrt.
Äh die Russen sind jetzt einfach kollektiv komplett aus den ganzen Zahlungsverkehr-Dingen der Welt abgeschnitten
ja, keine Kreditkartenzahlung mehr, nix online funktioniert nix
die Unternehmen können nix mehr einkaufen. Dazu kommt, dass jetzt viele Unternehmen abziehen. Irgendwie Ikea hat jetzt grade angesagt, dass sie jetzt alle fast nicht siebzehn Stores äh schließen und auch in Weißrussland und irgendwie,
auch auch nichts mehr aus dem Land äh rausforsten und so weiter.
Wenn wir denn jetzt noch die Swarovski-Kristalle wegnehmen, dann wissen die überhaupt nicht mehr, was sie machen können.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall äh jetzt,
Natürlich kommen dann irgendwie die Bitcoins und sagen, ah ja, hier, das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Irgendwie macht auch Bitcoin und so, weißt du, um mal einfach mal wieder ein paar äh in ihr System äh reinzulenken.
Sehr schön, wenn Leute wieder bereit sind, da irgendwie äh ihr Geld reinzustecken, dann dann dann können sie wieder besser verkaufen. Funktioniert ja auch, wie man sieht am Kurs.
Ähm und das mag vielleicht tatsächlich in der Situation, in der sich jetzt ähm Privatpersonen in Russland befinden, durchaus auch,
vielleicht eine Lösung sein
Ja, also bevor sie sozusagen ihr Geld, was jetzt an in in Rubeln existiert, äh kompletten Wertverlust äh unterliegt. So hätten sie halt die Möglichkeit, Theoretisch irgendwie darüber einen äh,
einen Umweg zu finden. Nur das ist natürlich überhaupt nicht gesagt ist, dass dass dieser äh dass dieses Geld dir ihren seinen Wert auch behält, geschweige denn, dass sie in der Lage sind, das so zu machen.
Also Tim, du hast jetzt gerade den russischen Staatsbürgerinnen empfohlen in Bitcoin zu gehen. Also.
Ich habe nur gesagt, das ist das ist so die Erzählung, die jetzt sozusagen im Netz äh,
durchgeführt wird. Warum warum das jetzt toll ist, ne? Das ist irgendwie ja. Und jetzt seht ihr ja mal, wenn ihr jetzt hier die starten, den Finanzfluss beschränken et cetera, ne? Also diese grundlibertäre,
Erzählungen, dass dass die Staatengemeinschaft da ganz böse ist und äh dass man ja so ein alternatives Zahlungssystem braucht.
Das fand ich auch sehr schön. Da gab's so einen heißen Artikel. Äh es geht ja nicht nur darum, also genau an diesen Aspekt, den du gerade meinst. Hier was ist denn, wenn jetzt keiner, wenn man die jetzt von Swift ausschließt und von Ausschluss von Swift ist ja im Prinzip.
Also der Swift, jedes Land also die Europäische Union kann sich ja zum Beispiel entscheiden einen äh,
eine bestimmte Sanktionen zu erheben, ne und dann ist der Verstoß gegen diese Sanktionen gewissermaßen unter Strafe. Das heißt, dann wird dürfen bestimmte Gelder nicht mehr in dieses Land gezahlt werden, in bestimmten Branchen, in bestimmten Bereichen oder sie gehen eben an dieses Swift, was,
der Juristriktion der EU unterliegt, ist mit Sitz in Brüssel.
Und sagen so, pass auf, ganz ganz trifft nicht mehr. Ein Swift hängt aber mehr dran als die Europäische Union. Das heißt, jetzt kann es theoretisch Länder geben wie ich glaube beispielsweise Brasilien, die über Swift.
Ihr äh Gaszahlen oder oder nicht ihr Gas-Ihre auseinandersetzen ihre ihr Business,
mit äh Russland klären und dass dann nicht mehr können. Das heißt, du hast jetzt eine Sanktion gezogen, die dafür sorgt, dass auch potenziell Länder betroffen sind, die vielleicht,
dieser Sanktionen sich gar nicht anschließen möchten. Ja? Und da gab's dann so einen wunderschönen Heiser Artikel Experte Doppelpunkt.
Äh es dauert bis das alles über Bitcoin abgewickelt werden kann oder irgendwie so was, ne? Und das fand ich sehr schön, weil jetzt muss man noch nicht mal mehr in einem bestimmten Fachbereich Experte sein. Man kann einfach Experte sein.
Das finde ich sehr gut. Er hatte mein Vater mir schon als als Heranwachsender für meine erste äh Visitenkarte empfohlen, der sich einfach nur Experte draufschreibe, ohne mich da jetzt irgendwie unnötig einzuengen. Ähm das fand ich äh fand ich sehr.
Das ist ein ganz guter Rat. Äh allerdings ich würde empfehlen draufzuschreiben Spezialexperte.
Spezialexperte.
Ja, weil weil Spezialexperten, weißt du, haben wir halt noch mal gegenüber den Experten den äh Vorteil, dass sie halt einfach im Speziellen dann einfach auch nochmal sehr viel qualifizierter sind, ne.
Spezialisierung auf auf Spezialexperte.
Ja, die Empfehlung ist halt ähm.
Genau, also so mit mit dem Angriff. Ich will diesen Witz nicht nochmal machen. Auf jeden Fall, die Vorstellung,
dass jetzt die Kryptogelder in irgendeiner Form eine Alternative für das russische Wirtschaftssystem sein können, ja.
Ist natürlich totaler Unsinn. Selbst also selbst wenn die das jetzt aktiv betreiben würden, ja, würde es natürlich Jahre dauern,
bis überhaupt so eine Infrastruktur in irgendeiner Form existiert, in der
alle Unternehmen und auch alle Privatbürger äh an so einem System teilnehmen würden. Dann wissen wir auch schon, das haben wir ja auch schon mehrfach rausgearbeitet, ist natürlich,
Bitcoin, das gilt genauso auch für alle anderen Kryptowährungen, überhaupt nicht geeignet
als Zahlungssystem, weil's einfach die die die fundamentalen Kriterien dafür nicht erfüllt, ja? Es ist viel zu volatil in seinem Wert. Äh die Transaktionen sind viel zu teuer, dauernd zu lange und umso mehr gemacht werden umso höher steigen die Preise. Also das ist halt einfach
äh vollkommen ungeeignet dafür. Das weiß mittlerweile auch jeder. Das heißt, das das würde sozusagen überhaupt nicht funktionieren
Das ist halt einfach einfach nur so wieder so eine so eine Erzählung, um einfach noch mehr äh Idioten in dieses System reinzulocken.
Na ja, aber das das Handelsvolumen in US-Dollar von Gas das willste schon in deiner Kryptowährung drin haben, wenn du deine Milliarden da irgendwann nochmal raustragen willst, ne.
Natürlich, das ist äh immer die Motivation, ne. Nichtsdestotrotz
kann aber jetzt durchaus äh Bitcoin theoretisch eine Rolle spielen, wenn's darum geht jetzt größere Summen irgendwie ins äh Trockene zu bringen.
Oder größere Summen an einen Kriegsverbrecher zu überweisen ähm unter
unter Umgehung internationaler Sanktionen und Echtungen. Ach nee, stimmt, für für Gas dürfen wir ja weiterhin bezahlen. Da da so weit haben wir äh uns ja noch nicht eingeschränkt, aber äh wenn der Fall käme,
dann könnte Bitcoin also hier eine eine neue Zukunft nicht nur
zur Finanzierung der organisierten Kriminalität, sondern auch eines Kriegsverbrechers in ins Haus stehen und da da muss man doch wirklich sagen, da schlägt das Kryptoherz doch direkt viel höher.
Ja, also ich meine Russland hat äh bei so einigen, nicht bei aber nicht allen, aber bei so einigen Crypto-Brons auch steht da auch schon immer hoch im Kurs, ne, also äh da gibt's schon immer auch äh entsprechende Verflechtungen. Ich,
sogar noch aus alten Zeiten einen, der irgendwie sich also auch sich auf Twitter da am Kopf und Kragen äh twittert, was das betrifft.
Äh aber das ist jetzt sozusagen durchaus auch eine Bedrohung, die gesehen wird und die man natürlich verhindern will, entsprechend steigt der Druck auf die Exchanges, ne, weil natürlich,
du halt problemlos innerhalb dieser Krypto Geld
Netzwerke da deine Coins hin und her überweisen kannst, wie du lustig und launig bist, weil das ist ja das Prinzip,
keine Zentralbank, die das verhindern kann. Du machst einfach deine Transaktionen. Die meiner bestätigen die fertig aus und dann ist das Geld weg nur.
Ding ist halt, solange es eben nur Bits sind, sind's halt einfach nur Bits richtig was wert wird's eben auch. Erst wenn's wieder ins normale Wirtschaftssystem zurück
und dafür gibt's halt diese Exchanges, ne? Die Schaufelverkäufer für die Goldgräber und äh die allerdings haben natürlich das Problem, dass sie äh dann natürlich auch wirklich echtes Geld anfassen müssen und dann äh so sie denn zumindest in den USA sind äh oder in anderen äh Ländern mit einem funktionierenden Rechtssystem
ähm dass ihr natürlich dann äh ein Stück weit jetzt auch schon Regulationen und Anforderungen äh.
Den USA hat also jetzt die beiden Administrationen sich an die Krypto Exchanges äh gewandt und darauf gedrungen, dass sie doch bitte, bitte, bitte äh nicht äh jetzt hier in irgendeiner Form
äh ein richtiges Geld umtauschen oder umgekehrt äh die jetzt irgendwelchen Russen gehören.
Wie sie das jetzt irgendwie feststellen sollen, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig und ähm tatsächlich haben also wohl,
Die größeren Plattformen sowie Binelands und und und Coinbase und FTX äh auch zu Kooperation,
zugesagt, was auch immer das heißen mag, ob sie das dann aber hintenrum tatsächlich äh tun, das das steht in den Sternen,
Also das muss man nochmal beobachten, wie sich das jetzt so äh entwickelt, aber hier
natürlich dann eine interessante Auswirkung dieser ganzen Erzählung der äh des unabhängigen Finanzsystems.
Ja, also das ist ja die die diese Grundidee oder dieser Grundraum so ja alles total unabhängig und keine Zentralbanken und eine eine Zensur freier Flow von Geld.
Ja? Immer unter diesem Aspekt oder unter diesem diesem diesem Gesichtswinkel im Blickwinkel, das,
dass das was Gutes sei oder was uneingeschränkt Gutes sei. Ja,
nach dem Motto, ja aber Assange hat ja seine Spenden bekommen und irgendwie ein Kambodscha kann ja irgendwie jetzt irgendein ein ein Influencer davon leben. Ähm.
Nur jetzt haben wir natürlich eine Situation, wo es eben auch genauso gut bedeuten kann, dass dieser Mangel an politischer Eingriffsmöglichkeit auch im Zweifelsfall bedeutet,
Sanktionen, auf die sich die internationale Gemeinschaft oder zumindest der Teil dem wir angehören, geeinigt hat, um einfach einen Krieg.
Mehr zu verhindern, aber zu verhindern, dass es irgendwie alles noch viel schlimmer wird als es ohnehin ist. Dass das dann halt einfach durch so ein System umgangen werden kann. Das ist natürlich,
ein Aspekt bei dem ganzen Tanz, den man nicht aus dem Blick äh.
Nehmen sollte. Insofern ist es halt auch hochproblematisch, dass eben jetzt die Ukraine auch selber anfängt darüber äh Spenden einzutragen. Das haben wir ja schon erwähnt.
Was haben Sie also Bitcoin.
Isar und Tewa, ne? Tewa ist diese Währung, wo sie die ganze Zeit vermuten, dass das äh die die die sagt, sie wären mit US-Dollar gebackt, aber wo sie Grund zu der Annahme haben, dass die die ganze Zeit hin und her schubsen zwischen zwei Firmen.
Dass das halt auch einfach so ein ähm.
Ja so ein Ding ist, was halt, wenn da wenn da ein Run drauf wäre, sofort in sich äh zusammenbrechen würde und bis dahin freuen Sie sich, dass Sie's haben. Äh.
Ja und vor allem die die seit Jahren behaupten irgendwie ja sie würden sich jetzt mal irgendwie einem Ordit unterziehen lassen und so weiter.
Nie getan haben und äh jeder eigentlich weiß, dass das ein Riesenscam ist.
Also es es ist schon auch ein ich frage mich auch wirklich, also.
Spätestens wenn mein wenn jetzt, sage ich mal, mein Start äh um Spenden in Bitcoin bitten würde.
Würde ich dann doch wahrscheinlich mal vorsichtig zur Bank gehen und ohne großes oh große Aufregung einfach mal fragen, ob ich vielleicht bitte ganz schnell all mein Geld haben kann, ne, weil äh also es ist ja schon auf eine Weise auch jetzt also,
unwahrscheinlich und ich hoffe auch wirklich nicht, dass es so ist, dass die Ukraine jetzt auf diese paar Millionen US-Dollar Spenden in Krypto Corencys angewiesen ist.
Ich hoffe es wirklich nicht für dieses Land.
Vielleicht sind das einfach nur die ukrainischen Ranson Wearleute, die sich jetzt darüber rauskaufen.
Ja also es ist es macht nicht alles Sinn, aber und auch dieser Aufruf zu dieser gemeinsamen Heimat eben macht keine gleichzeitig muss man vielleicht auch einfach mal würdigen dass ähm,
und jetzt suche ich nach dem richtigen Begriff, also sagen wir mal, die Art und Weise, wie wie es ihnen gelingt.
Zum Glück gelingt auch, ja, internationale Aufmerksamkeit zu erlangen, ähm den Kampfgeist der Bevölkerung aufrecht zu erhalten.
Und ja,
allgemein international mobil zu machen und äh durchaus eben sehr unter der Nutzung äh sozialer Medien äh ist beeindruckend. Ne, also der Silenski ist ja jetzt schon ein internationaler Held, den wirst ja demnächst
wie Che Guevara auf T-Shirts kaufen. Ja und mit Stolz tragen und ähm das ist ja schon ähm.
Erstaunlich und,
In einem internationalen äh Konflikt, wo du wo einfach mal eine absolute Übermacht unter nuklearer Drohung in dein Land einmarschiert, äh absolut überlebensnotwendig.
Insofern sehe ich in dem Kontext potenziell auch diese
Ich erwarte jetzt nicht viel aus dieser Telegram-Gruppe, die sich ukrainische Cyberarmee nennt. Ich glaube auch nicht oder ich hoffe nicht, dass das die fünf Millionen US-Dollar in Bitcoin oder was das da ist jetzt, für die einen relevanten Unterschied machen.
Aber es hält das Land und sein Leid.
In der in der öffentlichen Aufmerksamkeit und in dem Moment wo es daraus wo es da rausfiele, wäre halt auch aller Tage Abend für die.
Das ähm.
Insofern, ich bin da vorsichtig, dass jetzt irgendwie allzu äh beknackt äh zu finden, was die da machen, ne. Aber es.
Kryptospenden mal zu.
Ja, das ist völlig.
Na ja ich meine äh ähm wenn jetzt auf einmal fuols dazu beitragen, dass die Ukraine sich besser verteidigen kann, ja, dann würde ich sagen, okay.
Meinetwegen so, dann ist das jetzt äh äh kein schlecht investiertes Geld, ja und wenn dann irgendwie
so die Leute, die sowieso noch keinen klaren Weg gefunden haben, wie sie irgendwie ihre Bitcoins äh ein ordentliches Cash überführen können, sagen einfach, ja okay, die 20 Prozent, die die kriege ich wahrscheinlich sowieso nie komplett.
Ja, das.
Ne? Dann lassen wir das doch jetzt einfach mal den Staat äh äh waschen. Es ist.
Deine deine These ist im Prinzip, deine These ist im Prinzip ähm in ihrer Verzweiflung, nehmen sie jetzt auch Schwarzgeld.
Man muss ja einen Kanal machen. Ja, nee, das okay, das habe ich da wirklich neulich drüber nachgedacht. Ja, doch, natürlich. Klar, ja.
Wenn's um Leben und Tod geht ja, dann geht's um Leben und Tod, ne.
Denn also an das ja, dann nimmst du auch das Geld mit. Äh mit mit Krypto dran. Okay, ja.
Dafür ist aber ein bisschen schwach.
Bisher in den Walle.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was sie darüber eingenommen haben. Also.
Ich gucke jetzt nochmal.
Keine Ahnung, fünf Millionen US-Dollar habe ich jetzt bisher äh gehört, dass Maxi schon wieder geändert haben, dass es natürlich in der Tat wenig man darf jetzt allerdings und das muss man dazu sagen, jetzt auch nicht,
das so sehen mit,
oh ja, die arme Ukraine könnte ja sonst kein Geld kriegen, ja, das ist natürlich Unsinn. Sie hat jetzt in allen Ländern äh gibt es Lokale, Ibans, wo man irgendwie Kohle spenden kann. Das wird mit Sicherheit auch getan.
Ja
Zur aktuellen Bitcoin-Kurs im Moment ziehe ich gerade die Nullen richtig?
Also zum aktuellen Bitcoin-Kurs sind auf diesem Wallet eingegangen, zehn Millionen.
Rausgegangen äh neunhundertachtzigtausend und die haben eine Balance von äh ungefähr zweihunderttausend. Das Bitcoin Wallet in US Dollar, das heißt sie nehmen das Geld und äh transferieren es auch.
Jetzt schauen wir mal. Äh also zehn Millionen ist ja dann doch schon äh also ich meine okay, wenn die Milliarden haben, ist das immer noch schwach. Also da da geht noch was.
Aber okay und jetzt äh.
Okay das ist jetzt nichts. Das ist jetzt kein ich würde jetzt nicht sagen Tropfen auf den heißen Stein, aber das alleine,
nicht reißen. Also ich bin mir sicher, dass die Zuwendung äh international über die Nichtkryptowege sehr viel höher sind als das.
Ja äh klar, also ich bin jetzt auch ein bisschen enttäuscht von der organisierten Kriminalität. Ähm Ethereum da muss ich jetzt einen Block sagen. Nee, ich will wissen.
Ja letztlich auch egal wie viel es ist. Also wie gesagt ähm es macht das alles nicht besser,
Ja, also das ist halt einfach äh wir können uns eigentlich keine Systeme leisten, die halt äh potenziell solche Sanktionen hinterlaufen können und deswegen ist das irgendwie ein Problem und ähm,
Muss jetzt hier im Vordergrund stehen. Das,
die Ukraine unter Umständen jetzt durch solche Zahlungen profitiert. Das mag sein, ja?
Aber das ist nicht wesentlich und nicht nicht inhärent für dieses System.
Rennt für dieses System ist, dass es sich der Kontrolle entziehen will und äh genau das könnte halt auch noch ein sehr viel größeres Problem werden, wenn darüber tatsächlich Gelder transferiert werden, die ansonsten nicht transferiert werden.
Könnten von solchen Kriegsparteien oder ihren Förderern ähm weil eben internationale äh äh Sanktionen ähm.
Grade geschaltet wurden.
Das ist jetzt bei IFA richtig gesehen, habe vier Millionen.
Ja, aber es kriegst ja Raketen, kriegst dafür? Nicht viel.
Zu welchem Preis wir die Dänen verkaufen. Ähm.
Gut. Wer fällt mir da jetzt auch erst mal nicht zu ein?
Okay, weißt du, was ich äh ein bisschen äh also mir ist aufgefallen, dass äh es sogar in einer solchen Situation schaffen, äh unseren Galgenhumor zu bewahren?
Indem wir ja sehr geschult sind.
Müssen wir auch.
Müssen wir auch. Wir wissen ja jetzt inzwischen, dass Tim mit seinen goldenen Zwanzigern die ganze Zeit vom Letzten so vom Quartal vier,
zwanzig neunundzwanzig spricht, was ähm natürlich dann doch für die ein oder andere Hörerin ernüchternd ist. Ähm.
Ich hoffe, dass wir äh trotze des äh dass wir jetzt hier auch nicht unbedingt Gefühle verletzt haben, wenn wir auch in einer solchen Situation noch äh über Absurdität äh den Kopf schütteln.
Weiterhin äh tun, ne? Aber ich meine, Pandemieänder habe ich ja schon mal äh korrekt vorhergesagt, so das Ding ist jetzt eigentlich weitgehend durch und ähm jetzt haben wir halt ein neues Problem um das wir uns kümmern müssen.
Aber auch das wird irgendwann nicht mehr da sein.
War nicht alles schlecht mit covid-neunzehn.
Nee.
Es war nicht alles schlecht unter covid-19 wirklich nicht.
So, wollen wir's zu Ende bringen?
Ja, wir bringen es zu Ende.
Mhm. Sehr gut. Wer bringt's zu Ende? Du? Oder ich.
Ja wir waren heute bewusst mono äh thematisch klar und ich habe auch so den Eindruck, dass ähm das Thema wird uns noch eine Weile begleiten.
Wir hoffen natürlich äh das Beste und äh trotzdem muss man sich glaube ich so ein bisschen erst mal drauf einstellen, dass es alles noch äh etwas schlimmer wird, bevor es besser wird.
Von daher hm.
Ist jetzt glaube ich auch angemessen, dass man alles versucht beizutragen, was man äh in dieser Situation beitragen kann und da geschieht ja auch jetzt schon sehr viel.
Ähm,
Flüchtlingsaufnahme haben wir ja zum Beispiel viel Erfahrung gesammelt. Das sollte sich ja jetzt ganz positiv auszahlen äh können und natürlich muss äh politisch hier vor allem richtig gehandelt werden. Ich habe so den Eindruck.
Wie das immer so ist es hat auch alles wieder sein Gutes, da bin ich wieder mit meinem äh Optimismus, ne? Also wir sehen schon,
eine,
Ein Schließen der Rhein und sozusagen auch so ein bisschen äh die Rückkehr der der der Realpolitik, unter der sich dann eben bestimmte äh äh Debatten dann auch ähm.
Auflösen, die bisher vielleicht etwas irre geleitet waren. Europa ähm braucht einfach wieder einen ähm.
Ein ein ein gemeinsames Handeln, so ein ein ein,
eine Rückbesinnung darauf, dass es eben nur kollektiv äh vorangehen kann und ähm jetzt,
wird's ganz interessant sein zu sehen, wie vor allem das von Russland auch mit sehr viel Geld malträtierte und letzten Endes ja auch um seine EU-Mitgliedschaft gebracht äh äh UK äh sich äh verhalten wird in diesem ganzen Sport,
ihren Sicherheitsgarantien für die Ukraine gemeinsam mit der USA, ist ja nicht so viel übrig geblieben, inwiefern sie jetzt in der Lage sind,
ihren Finanzplan von von den Russen zu trennen, das wird sich noch zeigen, ne, weil all diese ganzen Maßnahmen sind halt vor allem Maßnahmen der USA und Maßnahmen,
der äh EU, aber die werden ja nicht uneingeschränkt genau so jetzt auch in UK durchgeführt. Das wird sich noch zeigen, wie sich das entwickelt. Na ja und ähm trotzdem,
jetzt eben auch.
Polen und Ungarn weitgehend erstmal im Boot. Ne, weil die jetzt äh merken, dass sie da genauso bedroht sind, ähm wie wir alle anderen auch.
Hm.
Na gut, aber zu diesem Zeitpunkt ist noch ein bisschen schwierig hier äh weitere Konsequenzen zu ziehen. Dafür bewegt sich äh derzeit noch zu viel.
Müssen einfach gucken, wie sich das entwickelt.
Und sagen eine Sache, die ich wirklich irre fände ähm.
Kenne mich jetzt nicht so so gut mit den ähm kriegerischen.
Geschichten aus, ne. Aber wenn es wirklich Gelenke der internationalen Staatengemeinschaft rein.
Finanzielle Sanktionen. Hier äh ein so ein Angriffskrieg.
Zum Erliegen zu bringen. Ne, so richtig zack, das ist mir nicht bekannt, dass das schon mal funktioniert hätte.
Ähm und das kann aber auch sehr gut sein, dass ich da falsch liege, aber ich fände es wirklich auf eine gewisse Weise wirklich irre, äh wenn wenn auch der ähm.
Der friedensorientierte Zusammenhalt, der Nationen.
Dieses Beispiel hätte durch eine reine quasi friedliche Blockade.
Kombiniert mit natürlich das angegriffene Land ähm mit Waffen äh zu versorgen, den einen Erfolg erzielen würde, der über nukleare Bedrohung, Panzer und alles hinausgeht. Ähm.
Durch durch Echtung und äh Sanktionen. Äh das wäre schon eine ein irrer Erfolg.
Und ähm und dann könnte man die hundert Milliarden, die wir jetzt äh in die Bundeswehr investieren, also Rheinmetall geben ähm sich eventuell auch wieder sparen. Das wäre doch ein tolles Zei.
Rheinmetall übrigens jetzt verkaufen Gewinne einstreichen und äh spenden wisst ihr Bescheid ne.
Ja sicher. Leute, könnt ihr doch nicht machen.
Ich hatte da keine Aktien.
Ich auch nicht, aber also äh zweiundsechzig Prozent, nee, 72 Prozent im letzten Jahr.
Gestiegen oder was.
Ja. Und in also in in den letzten fünf Tagen 40 Prozent.
Schämt euch.
Genau, das hättet ihr auch alles im Bitcoin stecken können.
Tschüss Leute, bis bald.
Tschau tschau.